♪ ♪
>> Sean: YOU MAY HAVE SEEN OUR
GRIPPING AND SAD INTERVIEW LAST
WEEK WITH HORACE LORENZO
ANDERSON SR., THE FATHER WHO
TOLD US ABOUT THE HEARTBREAKING
EXPERIENCE HE LOST HIS
19-YEAR-OLD SON IN THE SUMMER OF
LOVE, CHOPPED AND CHAZ ZONE.
NOW MR. ANDERSON HAS RECEIVED AN
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT INCLUDING
WE ARE TOLD A PHONE CALL FROM
THE PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND FINALLY A MEETING WITH
SEATTLE’S MAYOR.
HE RETURNS TONIGHT TO GIVE US AN
UPDATE ALONG WITH ANDRE TAYLOR.
MR. ANDERSON, THANK YOU FOR
BEING BACK.
EVERYBODY ASKS ME, NOBODY CALLED
MR. ANDERSON?
DURING THIS SHOW, AS IT WAS
GOING ON, THE WHITE HOUSE
SWITCHBOARD CALLED ASKING FOR
YOUR NUMBER.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED SINCE?
>> A LOT OF THINGS HAVE HAPPENED
JUST BECAUSE OF YOUR SHOW, I
BELIEVE.
I WANTED TO SAY FIRST OF ALL,
WANT TO GIVE MY HEART OUT TO
EVERYONE BECAUSE OF YOUR SHOW,
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT TO
THE WITH THE MOST, THE BEST,
AROUND THE WORLD.
I’VE GOTTEN CARDS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD.
PEOPLE I DON’T EVEN KNOW
REACHING OUT TO ME, SAYING THAT
YOU’RE A GREAT DAD AND DIFFERENT
THINGS.
I WISH I HAD A DAD LIKE YOU,
THINGS LIKE THIS, YOU KNOW.
IT’S BEEN VERY OVERWHELMING.
>> Sean: HOW WAS THE
PRESIDENT’S CALL?
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> KIND OF LIKE JUST, YOU KNOW,
BASIC, HE CALLED AND GAVE HIS
CONDOLENCES.
YOU KNOW, LIKE I SAID, A PHONE
CALL IS LIKE, YOU KNOW, I CALL
YOU AND TELL YOU I LOVE YOU.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
IT’S A DIFFERENT THING WHEN
SOMEBODY’S RIGHT THERE EMBRACING
YOU AND TELLING YOU YOU LOVE
THEM.
YOU CAN FEEL THE LOVE.
I’M NOT INTO POLITICS SO I DON’T
KNOW IF THE CONVERSATION WAS
JUST CONVERSATION.
>> Sean: MR. TAYLOR, WHAT
ABOUT THE MAYOR?
INEXCUSABLE, MR. TAYLOR.
SHE ALLOWED THIS TO HAPPEN.
SHE DIDN’T PROTECT
MR. ANDERSON’S SON.
SHE SHOULD HAVE PROTECTED THE
CITY, THE PEOPLE OF HER CITY.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
PRESIDENT’S PHONE BECAUSE WE
WERE BOTH ON THE PHONE CALL.
THE PRESIDENT WAS EXTREMELY
GRACIOUS.
HE CALLED AT A PERFECT TIME,
DURING THE FUNERAL SERVICES.
IT JUST LIFTED HORACE UP.
HE WAS ELATED, SCREAMING, I GOT
A CALL FROM THE PRESIDENT.
I DON’T WANT TO BELITTLE THE
POWER OF THE PRESIDENCY OR THE
SEAT OF THE PRESIDENCY.
IT WAS VERY, VERY SPECIAL FOR
HIM AND IT WAS VERY, VERY
SPECIAL FOR MYSELF.
WHATEVER YOUR POLITICS ARE, IT
DOESN’T MATTER.
THE OFFICE IS THE MOST POWERFUL
OFFICE IN THIS WORLD AND TO BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE A PHONE CALL
FROM THE PRESIDENT, HE GETS NO
HIGHER THAN THAT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
COVERED THAT.
>> Sean: I GOT A LOT OF
REACTION TOO AND EVERYBODY THAT
I HAVE TALKED TO, EVERYONE
THAT’S WRITTEN ME, EVERYONE I
SAW OVER THE WEEKEND SINCE THEIR
LOVE AND PRAYERS TO YOU AND I